being naked in the shower with a bunch
of dudes is totally not gay as long as
it's after a long day horsing around in
the hot sun on a sports team well I
thought you're gonna say if the lights
are off then the answer is always dead
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
today is a very big day on the yes or no
game not just because we have very big
people in the studio but because we have
multiple people this is the first ever
multiplayer yes or no game and you can
have your own multiplayer yes or no
games you go to dailywire.com shop you
can pre-order them it's going to sell
out again make sure you get it daily
wire.com slash shop gentlemen
Mr Knowles I'm joined today
by the crane and Company team
Mr Jake it in drink it in Mr David
present
I'm not this short yeah yeah it's
getting it's gonna hear you on an apple
bottom for your insecurities
look I'm in the six foot range yeah he's
eight foot three allegedly I don't know
I guess the camera takes away 10 inches
yeah
I told you the nephilimer real we get
Blaine in Apple box please yeah we need
to fly in an Apple box you know the
rules gentlemen that's true and I wanted
to make sure everybody in the audience
Center said look we're from the south
all right we drink cold beer and good
bourbon and whiskey all right that's
what we do so yeah we got a little bit
of the beautiful golden beverage or an
old cold sodas we call it back in East
Alabama
uh you know I haven't spent enough time
in Alabama I'm drinking uh what they
call in New York a very fruity drink uh
because it's look it's lent I've I'm
trying to give up booze and yet one of
my jobs is I have a drinking game yeah
so I'm having here this is my Sex in the
City cocktail no it's how Samantha of
you I just want to know uh you know does
your husband drink as well
yeah he does actually nice nice no we
actually call it something different in
Alabama
um no but uh look it's funny for Lynn I
actually drink alcohol during then I go
the opposite way like I do for for
during Lent I do something bad like
drink alcohol and the rest of the year
I'm good you try to you try to have 11
months yeah I'm hedging my virtue it's
buying insurance it's very interesting
yeah it is you can ask now on the game
when we have women play the ladies go
first but since you are men I will go
first no no sure all right well we'll
see who knows okay yeah here we go it's
20 23.
you should never be able to have your
Heisman taken away from you even if you
almost decapitate your ex-wife
well so I'm answering is you yeah and
I'm going to say oh yeah
okay we're maybe one
you can move that one okay one
well it's also it's kind of a double
negative yeah it's do you think you
should get your Heisman taken away it's
basically what you're asking yeah yeah
okay so I guess we play it as should it
get taken away yeah is there any
circumstance in which you should be
taken okay you ready
yes God I can get lost in those eyes
wow wow wait do I go this way
okay look man I grew up playing Candy
Land everybody calm down is all complex
Tron so I
I think
no you shouldn't lose your Heisman yeah
even if you okay kill your wife and a
waiter because
the Heisman is for athletic achievement
oh God spit it right so it's not it it's
you should go to jail if you kill your
wife in a waiter you should maybe be
executed if you kill your wife even
later but you allegedly allegedly if you
did it and if you write a book about it
for instance but like but you
it's not like you got worse at football
then that's true and well let me ask you
this what if you kill somebody while
you're playing like legitimately during
the season where you won the Heisman
then they give you the Heisman after the
season I mean can we retroactively say
Hey you cannot you can't be murdering
people on the field and off the field on
the yeah if you well I assume you've
you've got some sort of Indemnity right
I assume you I don't know I I I you'll
be surprised to hear I haven't played a
ton of football in my life
but I've also never killed anybody and I
think I don't know if in the course of
the game if you're so
excel at the game that you kill somebody
on the field
do you get another trophy uh look I mean
the real question is do you play
basketball for Alabama or not yeah
um uh that's just kidding kind of oh all
right all right you're right I don't
know no you got that wrong so you got a
drink oh yeah go good it's great to
drink
um
oh God that is just golden Beauty all
right
here we go
the train leaves Delaware no I'm kidding
wrong one all right the Ukraine flag in
your Twitter bio is more of a tell than
having pronouns listed
okay we're talking about foreign policy
versus gender identity this one these
are two heavyweights going at it you say
I'm gonna say
you got it wrong
Michael I thought I knew you dog you
didn't know that the reason it's more of
a tell if you have the pronouns in your
bio
you have some sexual confusion you I
don't know maybe you go along with fads
but you might just have kind of weird
sexual desires if you have the Ukraine
flag in your Twitter handle
what that signifies is you will go along
with the ruling class and the regime and
the establishment on anything okay it
will it just means the current thing
whatever the current thing that the
propagandists are pushing you'll go so
it actually has nothing to do can I tell
you my line of thinking what I thought
you think I I feel like in you have
stages of a person's mental capability
if you can't get past understanding
there's two genders then how in God's
name could you ever understand anything
like foreign policy so that's where my
mind was second thing is uh about
Ukraine I keep asking this question
nobody can answer me why do you have to
why can't you just be pro- something and
not give money to it like I love the
Atlanta Braves love them I'll watch 162
games but I'm not sending a third of my
paycheck to the Braves organization to
buy more foam fingers no can win this
zombie like hey you crave y'all go kick
their ass man good luck you want it hype
guy yeah we'll be the biggest hype that
you got here we go getting the money
Vladimir well that's confusing because
both of them look there's so many
Vladimir especially Transylvania over
there like with at the end of the day
the main thing is like hey we'll reach
you on but I'm not giving you the bag I
don't understand that yeah you're right
you could well I'm just waiting you can
meld them together for when they add the
the blue and the yellow to the the gay
flag so that'll be that that's going to
be the new well you know those Ukrainian
gays they're over there fighting as hard
as anybody yeah yeah yeah I was also
thinking
is crane like the most LGBT I don't I
don't know I've been over there in
advance week I don't plan on going so
I'll Drink To That Ukrainian gays let's
get it right so I'm up guys who say they
have a photographic memory are
compensating for something
boy this one feels awfully personal
um well there's no yeah there's no
question about that obviously yep all
right and then you'll move to wherever
you think
[Music]
no it's not all right I grew up in a
place where guys get huge trucks with
mud flaps that are under five foot eight
that's compensating for something yeah
right making a Twitter account burner
and not using your real name or tagging
somebody that's compensating for
something just because my mind takes
photos Okay and look it's not a great
thing I remember all the bad stuff too
it's like half and half do you you
really have a photograph man I can
remember numbers addresses all type of
sports stuff like who plays for who but
ask these guys there's not a coach I
can't name there's not a player I can't
name in his position wow Creighton
cockrunner Trey Alexander nimhar you
could just be saying names I don't I
could you know Smith Jones
too probably a Washington wow wow okay
that because I don't I don't have a
photographing memory I I have a worse
one I'm convinced that I remember
certain things and then I'll be I'll
later find out I was completely wrong my
therapist would just do wonders with you
I would just love you you didn't have
the thing to say yeah it is a Samantha
thing to say it's no power man this is
fun I like this game I need to order one
of these the answer is always yes
they're already out I ordered a thousand
just now so we're trying to get some
during Christmas that's better than the
game uh that I used to play so are you
talking about earlier
no not camping does does it smell like
chloroform game oh oh yeah that was the
other game yeah
crazy things happen to the baseball team
makes you better yeah it does
are you are you oh for three
um first time in my life Michael
whatever is done look look I I feel like
I had some good answers though you did
some good some good theories that's all
I wanted to quit drinking so he could
have been trying to get those right
David stop telling them so we've got
three more questions all right here we
go you ready for the hurricane all right
here it is
God you guys are a different flavor evil
dressing in suits every day is
equivalent to short guys wearing height
altering shoes both are just ways to
make people think you're more important
than you are
this was fun
okay so I answer is you you yes yes
foreign
but did I get yours correct
yeah yes the the thing is though some
people do that some people dress in a
suit they look it's a total joke you
know because they don't need to be but
what if they what what if they are that
important if Donald Trump shows up to
work in sweatpants that something's gone
wrong he is important enough either that
or it's going really right
um my thing about suits is this there
are some professions and I'm speaking
about anomalies here where you need to
wear a suit when I'm talking about suit
I'm talking about Thai yeah I'm talking
about the whole get up not the hey you
know I'm going to the Frat party types
so to me if you're wearing a suit and
like yeah basketball coaches that wear
suits like during the game our football
coaches that wear suits oh my God Al
golden wore a suit when he was at Temple
I believe and this man looked like he
just went to a water park he'd be just
sweating it's basically an Old Spice
commercial I just again I feel like it's
like the big truck Theory what have you
ever comment saying for what are you
hiding under there yeah that's my real
question an undershirt yeah so uh look I
got the first one right and you got it
right that's correct okay now maybe I
get to drink yeah
yeah man that's tell you what you ever
play The Bull Moose game ah not since uh
the landslide I love the 70s
we would play this game my buddies I
guess we started in college we played
throughout my 20s though where if you
were holding your drink in your right
hand and somebody called you out moose
then you have to chug it and if if you
falsely accuse somebody then they have
to chug their drink and and sometimes
you can fake people out because you'd
say you know I'd be kind of like this
you know and you'd be like bull moose
and then I'd pull this up and I said I'm
double fisting I'm the man so you have
to drink now that that's a game I think
we can all get behind and it's family
friendly moose BS yeah that's if only I
had thought of that 15 years ago you
guys played Wayne we just played like
beer pong and yeah walk around trying to
find girls like to talk to just to talk
to yeah to compliment yeah yeah calm
down uh so now I'm
to you being naked in the shower with a
bunch of dudes is totally not gay as
long as it's after a long day horsing
around in the hot sun on a sports team
what are you going to say if the lights
are off then the answer is always yeah
um this is totally not gay so well I
feel like this one's this is kind of a
fastball for you I mean I've spent times
in locker rooms yeah oh yeah yeah I mean
listen man when I when I would spend all
those days you know out on the old Greek
wrestling team and never been to Greece
yeah
yeah yeah it's great it got greasy oh
good
um
so I'm answering you so okay so you're
saying
it's not gay so yes it's not gay or yeah
I would say either yes it's gay or no
it's not gay okay all right here we go
uh one two three
yeah
go get it I'm waiting on him to move his
first man it's called strategy calm down
totally no I think
[Laughter]
great job team no it's not getting the
sense that it definitely involves sweaty
men who are largely naked uh do be doing
weird stuff and like snapping towels and
stuff but
so it
the reason it's not gay it's like the
reason Achilles and patroclus are not
gay no no is because gay
is this modern idea that you know men
and women are kind of the same and you
can enter interchange men and women you
have a gay marriage and it's like gay is
so the idea of gay is so soft whereas
when I think of Achilles and patroclus
even if they were doing some weird stuff
in the showers in the locker rooms or
whatever like these are hard dudes these
are you know men who are slaying the
Trojans and so even if it's a little bit
like light in the loafers it's not gay
well I just want to give you credit for
using the adjectives of soft and hard in
that without making it weird
um my thing until now until now of
course it's my job I bring it back in I
bring the awareness back in here's my
thing we talk about togetherness by
teams you can go out and practice hard
together yeah you can go out and have
dinner at Beef O Brady's together and
really just you know get into each
other's families you're not really
together no I've seen you naked and
you've seen me naked yeah yeah all right
you want to talk about forming a team
yeah those of you all go group hug in
the showers yeah it's like this in the
longest yard but my my my thing is it's
team we end to a certain point you know
you kind of get used to it like uh but
there is one thing I want to say let's
make sure we keep men in the men's
locker rooms and women in the women's
locker rooms when it comes to sports I
want to make sure yeah because it's
always really weird when when you're
doing all that gay stuff in the men's
locker room yeah a woman while you're
watching
I'm trying to see chicks they don't want
me to do the other one anymore yeah no
they don't okay uh so you're right yeah
this is the last one this is your last
one yeah my last one here we go let me
get your uh drink
your drinky cheese hold my hair all
right here we go in general receive the
advice and constructive criticism here
we go from a woman is easier
than from another man
I'm gonna say no you move that I'm gonna
move this one well it's a fake out you
ever heard of a place yeah I'm gonna say
hmm
wrong again I mean are you serious yeah
no it's why it's way harder to take
criticism from a woman than from another
man well my thing is at the end of the
day which woman are we talking about
here I mean my mom
I mean look nobody's taking more
criticism from my mom yeah I'm talking
about my fiance we call that Tuesday
yeah so like it's much different if one
of my boys is over here not joking with
me yeah you know making fun of me or
something oops you fell down oh you
forgot to pay the gas bill whatever
whatever but it's an you know I don't
want to have to legitimately have you
know have it out with my boys yeah with
the bras because this summer we're
thugging it out with the bras yeah no
it's a thought yeah you're gonna be
there I'm ready you're ready
you think though
yeah I sort of see that but it like with
a with a guy if if I'm gonna criticize a
guy or sincerely criticize a guy or he's
going to criticize me I find it's I can
just sit down and be like hey what you
did you screwed that up that was stupid
you know it messed me up it's bad for
you and you you're you're just a
degenerate and you got to get your life
together okay we're good all right fine
yeah
an intervention good good well I went
and see all that we all wrote letters
but if it's with your wife or your even
some other female relative or friend I
just find it you can't be that blunt
often with women and it's because men
and women are different so it's like
then there's this lingering kind of yeah
yeah see I look it's 2023 as Blaine says
equal rights equal fights I'm gonna be
as honest with you as I'm anybody like
if I don't like it like we're out
playing basketball we're gonna find out
we need to know who makes better chicken
parmesan you do who's taking it to the
paint making the right decision that's
your boy but again at the end of the day
yeah
[Laughter]
wow hold on yeah
yeah no we get look I mean uh again and
I I just want to make sure that when it
comes down to me getting criticized my
fiance criticizing me about something is
one thing yeah I'm gonna internalize
that I'm gonna work on that then I don't
want to come to work and my brother be
like hey man that dinner y'all put on
last night wasn't worth it yeah like
that's a different thing to me you're
like yeah I don't need to hear that no
okay fair enough fair enough you do have
to drink because oh God please say I
won't say moose or whatever it was so
now
full moves
uh Mr Connor all right you want me to go
let's do it all right hey good job good
job I feel we all won Mr cone I thought
that was just going to be a stare down
for as long as possible breaks you're
familiar with the rules of the game I
think so and I've watched every episode
you're as familiar as I am okay because
you're very
you're competitive I mean you were a
real athlete I would like to win this
I'd rather win this okay all right
so I go first because you're a man
in theory the
prevalence of social media only serves
to promulgate and validate the
ideologies of both Dionysus and
Narcissus
I'm with you very Bach and alien I'm
still reading okay it says dot dot dot
JK
that's all guys that they die early
there are so many layers this got dark
really the prevalence of social media
only serves to promulgate and validate
the ideologies of both Dionysus and
narcissists
it's true what they say about tall guys
they die earlier okay wow so I guess we
are this is most responding it is we're
responding to the final Point tall guys
die early
okay well filled out
I do okay
um
I'm responding as you
like I guess statistically I don't know
what I'm saying if it makes you feel
better left-handed die two years earlier
on average that's true yes do you know
why I think what do you all do when
you're all alone
what are you guys I think it's
mechanical accidents actually really so
I'm not in a huge risk as it happens not
baseball plan I have to have to change
up on weekends but yes I mean look
science is science right I'm taller the
the heart has to pump the blood farther
through the body I get all that how
about to this first point though the
social media only serves to promulgate
and validate ideologies of both Dionysus
and narcissists no
you want to do that part well you just
kind of you just gave the answer I say
you say no
I say you say no social media can serve
other purposes other than bacchanalian
Elements of Life
just call him well so your answer is
obviously now friends
yes I guess my question is like
I guess I guess my question on this is
like
you could probably find a good use of
crocodile in that crazy Russian drug
that turns you into a leper and melts
your brain I'm a show frame of reference
I'm sure you could find
I know he's talking about you know
crocodile you know you remember man you
remember the early 2000s spring break
yeah like I'm sure you could but the
primary use of it okay the Practical
effective in the world but that's not
what it said okay I guess you're right
so we'll take that as two for two yeah
one question
we got to come back here wow we gotta
come back we're down right now okay you
said okay okay 500. oh you're right all
right here we go I'm up question you
will learn more leadership skills and
life lessons playing sports through
Middle School and High School than you
will for four years at some garbage
College
like Yale
then that's pointed then you will learn
playing sports at some garbage call like
no just four years there you will learn
more about leadership leadership skills
and life lessons playing sports through
middle school and high school then you
will from four years at some garbage
College like Yale like you okay
um so I'll answer for you you answer for
me
uh you're gorgeous
so
you did guess correctly but only because
of one word there the word was and
because you certainly would learn much
better leadership skills yeah
playing sports in middle school and high
school than you would at Yale but
the and is the issue here because the
life lessons that you learn at a place
like Yale
is how to just be
how to survive surrounded by the most
sociopathically ambitious you've ever
met in your whole life the sharkiest
it's it's all they're all Pete bootage
they're all and they're all these guys
who are just like huh oh well uh you
know only probably only one of us is
going to be president someday so if you
if if even your slight shoulder gets in
the way of my ambition I'll rip your
heart out and eat right in front of you
my dad has a wave runner yeah it sounds
like you're speaking from experience I
have met a few of these guys in my life
playing sports you learn all sorts of
things we talk about it all the time the
values that it instills on us you know
punctuality and discipline and all those
sorts of things but there's a there's a
there's a phrase become a millionaire
not for the million dollars but for what
it will take of you to become a
millionaire right substitute going to
deal with that graduate from Yale not
for the degree yeah but for what it will
take to get through all of that as well
there you go now not for the degree but
not worry yeah okay also only for you do
I drink beer that what do you ordinarily
drink whiskey yeah naturally no cones
like a savant like this is like this
isn't like hey we messing for you but if
we're gonna drink it that's the kind of
glass
I know that's the problem when you keep
winning this then you don't get to drink
it as much
[Music]
when you lose you have to drink it when
you win you get it yes I just refuse to
let you know that go away so we're gonna
get to the bottom
sports betting is technically a sin
that's good
[Music]
Michael
all right
I think sorry amigo
talk to me talk to me it can be sinful
if you you know if you bet the farm on
you know the Yankees or something but
have you done that uh yeah I'm going
close yeah yeah but when your namesake
was was pitching look maybe there'll be
something in there about these buses but
no uh bets are I'm all for gambling if
it's within reason it's only when it's
like booze you wouldn't say drinking is
intrinsically sinful I mean the first
miracle of Christ is turning water into
wine for people who've been drinking for
like three days okay the but getting
drunk is a sin you know getting just
like degenerate wasted being a drunker
that's a sin but you know so it's like
gambling you know you
so you're on the the apollonian
philosophy of moderation and all things
including moderation including that's
kind of where you're going with that
well yeah I I'm there are many examples
of um moderation and moderation like but
those are unfit for you know public
consumption again look I often say some
of some of the Fondest Memories I have
from high school are poker games with my
friends totally that kept us out of more
trouble oh didn't develop a gambling
addiction from that yeah or like I
remember back when I was in Middle
School like we'd go down and go to the
local cockfighting ring and it was like
very nice and wholesome it was it was a
lot of a great job
because I want to hear more about that
yeah well it's again if we'll just take
the national debt and put this on
Alabama to cover their first two games
we'll be making them you'd probably hit
for sure
all right question two for you so much
about the former athlete that's in
quotes former athlete stereotypes is
easily explained by the repeated head
trauma so much about the former athlete
stereotypes is easily explained by the
repeated head trauma
okay I'm prepared to answer
wrong again
did I get yours right no I got YouTube
look he's gonna match those with no
former athlete all right so the other
option if you're saying it you know that
what are the former athletes uh insults
you know that I don't know not that
bright or not so you know and so you're
saying you blame it on the head trauma
well the only other option is that
you're a big dummy or something but in
my experience like that's kind of The
Jock stereotype but in my experience
that isn't true in my experience
athletes tend to be pretty smart and
even like super smart guys who are
pretty grounded
can be pretty athletic too I think of
super gigachad Dr Spencer Clavin you
know that guy or you think of the one of
the greatest sounds
stereotypes here is interesting because
it's not the former athletes who are
creating the stereotypes it's everyone
out there around them I think the the
the idea you're just saying stereotypes
being dumb like that stereotype being
created could easily be explained by a
resentment for people who didn't have
success in athletics let's see let's see
the wording here you tell so much about
the former athlete stereotypes is easily
explained
so it's a good that's a good answer and
you changed your mind and I was right no
no it
if you were to say the primary reason
that former athlete stereotypes exist is
resentment caused by pipsqueaks who
couldn't get on the team I I would be
inclined to believe that but if it just
says so much about it is explained by
the head drama then I to me the only
options are they're dummies or they've
been injured and I think it's the latter
also there's something that comes before
the success on the field too which is
like what are the odds just
statistically speaking that someone is a
really really great athlete but also
extremely smart so if they become a
really great athlete and they lack in
other areas that's another reason to
point out whatever weakness they make
right that's yeah yeah that's a that's a
fair point what are the odds of both of
those striking you still haven't changed
my mind I mean 100 well you know well
that's four it's clearly I bet Michael
yeah I forgot why I was here
when he said Apollonia I didn't know how
I got here it really melted have another
beer with apples that is yeah okay good
I was right where Apollonia refers to uh
you're you sir I read this one you read
that one okay
maybe I have some head drama okay
allowing your son to
oh boy you stopped there
allowing your son to participate in
theater is more of a gamble than letting
your daughter play softball
uh well wow the second part of that
question really complicates it yes it
does yes it does so allowing your son to
participate in theater is more of a
gamble we're making an assumption there
that we're gambling on the outcome of
their masculine of something more of a
gamble than allowing your daughter to
play softball and I think that Michael
Knowles
no correct okay did I get that one right
is more of a Gamble
no wow oh I think no tell them tell them
I think no and I'll tell you why I
you may not know this about me but I was
an extra in the play Macbeth at the
University of Michigan and it was set
during World War II and I turned out
just fine I got up there I cried my eyes
out you know and you know what it helped
me become a better video producer and a
director which led me to meet Jay crane
which is why I'm here today now I can't
speak to playing softball no I only knew
that fear leads on Thursday night but my
daughter's only five weeks old so we'll
see but now you tell me yours because
look there is a risk if you I mean I I
first of all found this to be a bit to
my advantage because
when I I was in theater from a very
young age and
I I was in the minority of men who were
in theater who were attracted to women
there you go and so I found well this is
great because now right just the numbers
are working out very much in my favor uh
but but it's a it's a bit of a risk you
know plenty of people turn out really
weird after being in theater Dylan
Mulvaney kind of thing and um
with softball
I'm just I'm just running the numbers in
my head here and it would just seem
just from my friends who played softball
it was more of a certainty that that
would be associated with certain
inclinations okay than even that theater
would be a male thespian yeah okay I
think we've got to understand the
difference between High School softball
and college softball I think in college
softball it is way way more prevalent
it's 100 cool right you can get away
with it by the way I did finish second
with my boy Maddie Middleton and Troy uh
I was in theater my senior at high
school we did Abbott Costello Who's on
First did you finish second how about
that you see that wow this guy's an
abigas that's the athleticism I'm in
Macbeth you know that what were you in
um
some of my buddies on the football team
they married girls from the softball
team and they have four or five kids wow
hey okay it's a real life story let's go
wow all right I love putting down
ponytail down theory is a real it's a
real explain explain that to Michael
Knowles so ponytail up is you're you're
gay yeah ponytail down like no ponytail
you're not gay watch a softball game too
many ponytails you see yeah really just
watch it you have six questions to deal
with that guy right the more you know
this is like the phrase lesson out yeah
I came up with that come on our show
anytime all right question number three
despite Giselle
being both a cheating and practicing
witch Tom Brady is still mostly to blame
for their split because he played
football for four more months I cannot
wait for this one I'm so excited okay
okay you ready yeah Tom Brady is still
mostly to blame absolutely not he is no
he's not not he's not so I guess this
could be a little bit of a technicality
he's not mostly to blame because he
played football for four more months but
he is mostly to blame because he is the
head of the household and the husband is
the head of wife as Christ is the head
of his church and so he's has a
leadership role in the household and he
has to keep the the whole thing together
and and so you know we have terrible
divorce laws in America no fault divorce
all this frivolous nonsense
and maybe she's a witch she does seem to
do kind of witchy weird stuff which is
not great and maybe he should have
thought about that before the marriage
but
I still
I put more of the blame and
responsibility on the husband so so
before I tell you my opinion I want to
make sure we understand that we don't
have any sort of inside information on
their relationship if if Tom Brady
committed infidelities that we don't
know about or practice with that well
that sounds one person was yeah that
that much is this video confirmed but
just from what we know the concept that
Tom Brady wanted to continue playing
football and for that he ruined his
relationship and created all this these
these memes you know that you care more
about having your worst season in the
NFL than you do about staying with your
family how old is Tom Brady he's 45
years old he wants to go to work he
doesn't want to retire I know 85 year
olds who can't retire how many people
have you heard about they retire and the
next week they die right is that what
that's what keeps them going this man's
45 years old he wants to go to work for
what to provide for his family and
that's what he did and then for Glory
too and he's doing a glory I mean I'm
not down on going to work the man wants
to go to work he wants to go to work
there's nothing wrong with that let him
go to work what is he supposed to do
he's supposed to stay home all day and
like for like now be the stay-at-home
dad I heard all these excuses of Gisele
sacrifice so much and now it's her turn
to to go on vacations what are you
talking about the man wants to go to
work and this idea that well with all
the money that he has you don't have to
work anymore that to me tells you that
people now only identify going to work
with the monetary gains that you get not
with the Fulfillment that comes with it
and that to me is a mistake but of
course there's easier ways to make money
Tom Brady probably could make just as
much money so he signed with Fox already
he starts with Fox next year 2024. 375
375 375 million for I believe 10 years
and he's playing earnings playing
earnings for the last 20 years were
about that maybe a little less yeah see
there you go that um so I it's obviously
that's going to work wow that's going
what's he gonna he's not going to be at
home with the kids no of course in her
father so no it's one of these where I
mean she seems to be a witch that's like
the kind of the weirdest thing about it
to me but
it's
it's sort of like if you want to oppose
feminism as I do
and and like all feminism from the very
beginning of feminism as I do
then I think you also have to say all
right if if men are going to have
the Privileges associated with
traditional life then they have to bear
some of the responsibility and sure it's
we're in a political culture now that
totally denies that right this is why I
encourage the Knowles prenup which is
you sign up before you get married and
it's whoever breaks up the marriage
loses everything there you go the kids
you do that yeah oh I had a problem in a
couple months yeah
I knew I waited for something yeah yes
well the statement Tom Brady could have
done more to save his marriage is most
likely accurate yeah like that that much
but but I agree that it's not
you know because he wanted to work yeah
he's a young man I agree so cheers to
that sir so is that it you're done now
switch all right Mr Crane Mr Knowles
your team is is not not doing right
Mr Cohen brought it back a little bit
but this is it's on you to be the closer
closer for we got a little Mariano
follows David Cohn you know right yeah
yeah or you're a Yankee fan yeah they
see him in me a couple months ago
it's kind of a rocky situation right now
that's right they didn't they see it in
me yeah and then they did exactly what I
said they're going to do yeah I didn't
apologize yeah I'm surprised my madness
you never get the apology this is gonna
be fun okay ready
trans men should be allowed to compete
in men's sports because you can't just
inject testosterone to make up for a
lack of masculinity like meaning if
you're a man but you're like a little
fopish you know you can therefore trans
men meaning women should be allowed to
compete
hmm I wonder what you're gonna answer
Michael this is a real tough one right
here
all right
correct oh good
oh good hey come on make faces at him
dog
[Laughter]
obviously obviously
do you think guys it's because they're
guys it's because they're guys they're
guys at the end of the day oh no you're
saying the women who say that they're
men they are basically guys yes
don't you think
that men look I'm not saying if some
roided up testosterone injected hulking
Amazon of a woman
only Rosie O'Donnell competed against me
in a I don't know game of peanut oil or
something I guess she could beat me
probably though I actually don't know
men are that men have that much of a
physical advantage that but let's just
say that that's the case
it doesn't change the fact that she's a
woman she's a woman down to her very
essence you know that the technical term
for this is is that your sex is an
Inseparable accident of the individual
meaning your body and soul United in a
hylomorphic union your sex comes from
your body not from your soul because we
we don't have different souls for men
and women we're not different species
so you're still a man you're still a
woman and then Sports very much of
sports is figuring out where the men
stack up in the pecking order so you can
have the shrimpy guy and you're gonna
have the super bosses yeah yeah exactly
and so I just you can't
to to say that
the
the masculinity or lack of masculinity
is just the measure of being a man
itself manhood itself seems crazy to me
because the whole point of sports is
just like okay how how Macho are you but
you're still a man you're still in men's
sports so
the amount of testosterone I saw a girl
or whatever you want to call it whatever
cave she came out of get injected with
enough testosterone to where she could
probably rip my arms off and my legs off
if she wanted to I think it just changes
up a little bit I I think we can all
agree yeah you're saying at the very
least even if she's not a man it would
probably not be safe for her to be
competing against the women yes no no
way it is there's no way it is they need
to have what their own class yeah right
they need to have their own class at the
end of the day you want to be special we
want privacy yeah we know you had your
own class maybe their own time because
it's bored yeah
yeah you know you just have an arena
everybody's there you just film stuff
you know something happens we have a
saying on our show bottom line keep your
keep your wiener out of women's sports
exactly so if you go all the way yeah
then okay okay all right I needed that
little comeback City huh yeah it didn't
oh do I get to drink this
yeah you did right so you accurately
guessed mine I accurately guess yours
correct correct all right
all right say hi again you know what
a man should always pay on the first
date even if the woman was rude not fun
and total mid
overall and fat
I added that I probably would have known
that going in right maybe not but yeah
Michael okay hold on look at me I got it
now you got it you know you know the
answer and you're not gonna fall for one
of those fake outs no I never did okay I
just wanted to close it yeah yeah all
right we'll let him try that one ready
one two three
um
the answer and then I think yeah
I think a man should always pay on the
first date yeah even if she's the worst
totally right and if you're on dating
apps they usually are yeah right I
actually missed it I totally missed it
good for you they're the worst
um even if she sucks even if she's I
would say a gen Z girl which is
basically like the your first 15 minutes
of a conversation where the Moon is in
the sky when you were born which is the
worst aren't only fans or anything like
that where was only fans when you were
born yeah I don't know you knew you knew
what you're walking into because like
usually on a first date it's not like
you haven't talked before or have no
idea what this person is about or or
what they believe in or how they are but
I was raised I do believe if you take a
girl out I always say this I'm gonna
take you out the first three three dates
I'm gonna buy dinner for you so you can
cook dinner for me for the rest of my
life that's right that's nice I agree
wow I think it's very generous let it
cook let them cook you're the man you're
you're the pursuing party here you're
not uh you you don't want to you don't
want a girl you as soon as she's the
worst is talking about astrology or
whatever you don't
you don't you don't want her to feel
like it's this is some commercial
transaction exactly this is a potential
love affair and sometimes I feel lesser
as a man if I don't pay you know I
really do I agree okay
you're overachieving right now I got to
be honest yeah absolutely crushing
friends don't let friends fall victim to
disgusting vices like watching The Big
Bang Theory or dipping
those two are just I don't know how
those two got correlated into the same
question but now the
um
okay
one two three
so the reason you're right
I knew it if it had been and you would
have been wrong but because it's because
dipping
totally fine very cool Big Bang Theory
completely unforgivable oh the worst
thing ever man yeah yeah so I thought
I'm not like crazy about Seinfeld but
it's I enjoy it it's not the greatest
show ever made but it's good I'm one of
those I'm one of those guys who look I
mean would your if your best friend
jumps off the cliff would you yeah
you're damn right I am yeah you are a
damn right that's why y'all went Club
diving with him that's why you ask
questions or anything like that you'll
ask questions later yeah in hell yeah
exactly exactly I don't ask permission I
just ask for a kid yeah yep okay uh
Europe
you ready for this yeah all right this
is wow I didn't realize
brother energy finished let's go let's
go my ninja Focus good
it's worse if you have physical squish
than it is to be a political squish
worst to be a physical Squish and to be
a political okay what's a squish a
squish you know is like
like a kinda like uh like uh you
know like a wuss like a beta wimp like a
beta like uh like someone who's gonna
compromise you know and so a physical I
mean I don't know what a physical squish
is I don't know if there's a little dig
from Ben Davies
or anything but
if it means listen this is this is
actually something I know you guys look
at me like Michael you're an Adonis you
must go to the gym every day I don't I
haven't been together thank you I
appreciate it I know you know the uh the
camera adds two packs actually really
cool but uh you know I don't hit the gym
a lot and I actually think
it's a problem I think I should hit the
gym I think it is good you want
excellence in all parts of your life and
you don't want to ignore that I mean you
think about the great philosopher is
they didn't think that you could just
ignore your body you know we're physical
beings we're incarnate so so that's bad
but is it as bad
as a being a political squish that's the
question
like physically
that sucks ready
correct he's absolutely
more proud to be your brother come on
I've never been together at this moment
came to me in a dream no you didn't I
didn't oh man the thing like the thing
about this when it comes to being like
politics and political squish most of
them are anyways I mean 99 of them right
well it doesn't matter what happens or
what's going down or who did this or who
did what they're going to fall on the
line or whatever party they're including
journalists too especially nowadays of
course it's about money with them but I
do think when it comes to physical like
it's see the thing about you might like
you might not be the most Jack guy
around but you know rich or not tell him
you're not some 300 pound guy walking
around yeah that's what I was gonna say
at the end of the day like you are
keeping yourself in shape like I might
not I might not go to the gym a lot but
I do a ton of code look yeah exactly
there you go that takes you but wait a
certain amount of aggression right to do
that and I think it's a lot a lot worse
to Let Yourself Go physically yeah than
it is to be a political squish because
99 of them are anyway oh she's saying it
is worse oh so no I'm saying it it's
it's worse to be a political okay
it's worse I might have got this wrong
that's wrong but it's worse to be a
physical squisherman yeah yeah so yeah
okay there it is there it is yeah
because I don't believe in any of those
guys anyways Republican Democrat doesn't
matter they're going to say what best
fits the moment in the situation that's
often I don't think of you as physical
squish like I don't either I'm big and
strong and sexy well two to your point
getting the gym and phone up three
rounds I'm not either no it's here to
say you ain't trying to fight nobody man
yeah don't don't die don't be disgusting
you're not eating four pizzas a night
yeah no no shoving your face full of
Taco Bell and Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
no there's a time and a place for that
was once I did that before well you're
eight to eight foot four like it goes
straight to your legs if it takes it
right to my finger it would take you 800
years to get fat you look good Mike
those guys you're a Yankees fan yeah
that's such a Samantha say you want to
do karate in the garage
come on
it's more difficult to stay on your
grind as a single sexy beat it was
absolutely bombarded by thirsty gold
digging models constantly trying to trap
you into 18 years of child support than
it is being a married man balancing work
and family so just to clarify I was a
bit wordy yes for the struggles of the
single Chad
and no for the family
I wish you could read that question and
look me in the eyes
I was hoping that was going to happen
I'll probably memorize it afterwards so
yes it's harder to be the single chat
you know this one you know this one
ready
I'm right
you're wrong
Who Wants To Be A Millionaire to you
yeah
having uh you know listen man I look
back at my Chad days
through it's sort of like Kodachrome you
know everything looks worse in black and
white but
it's harder it's harder you've gotta I
right now as a married man
I don't need to I don't need to swipe
right I don't need to go in dates I
don't need the anxiety of that I don't
need to worry about you know I'm going
to have HR breathing down my neck
because I looked the wrong way at
somebody I don't I don't need to worry
about cooking I don't need to worry
about cleaning I don't need to worry
about my family yelling at me that I'm
not settling down I don't need to worry
I don't pay my bills I don't I don't
know I don't I don't even know how much
money we bring in my wife handles
everything yeah takes care of me makes
me a home when I was single
it was rougher I think a lot of the
doing me is mindset right
when you're do I get did I guess right
yes you did yeah you did um when you're
a single guy or stuff like that if
you're just going out I mean if if
you're getting approached by models all
the time it must be nice congratulations
um that's not really a tough thing you
feel will to deal with just be in the
house that don't talk that much
um
but I think it's a lot harder to one
take care of a family
um and I know not every situation is
probably the same situation with you
have the great wife you have the great
wife who does you know so I think it's a
lot harder to take care of a family
raise kids you know pay a mortgage or
something like that than a single guy
who has a mindset of I'm not worried
about a bunch of females or this I'm
gonna get in the gym I'm gonna eat my
protein a certain amount of calories a
day I'm gonna do what I need to do
you're so scheduled out and I feel like
when you're a family you have kids
everything's chaos yeah everything's
chaos and your job as a father is to
Wrangle in this chaos and there's
nothing tougher to do than to control
chaos yes and as a father I feel like
you do that on an everyday basis not
only with yourself but with your family
too as a single Chad I just have to
Control the Chaos in my mind right and
if I can channel that become a Monster
yeah right become a monster and learn
how to control it but that's the point
that's the hard part of the Temptation
when you're just that single Giga Chad
just you know rolling around the streets
how do you control the chaos at least
I'm like regimented right so I agree
with you on this you see what I'm saying
yeah well we all know Chad stands for
cool hot and down
we certainly have more responsibilities
with kids and with your home right like
you like you said but it's easier for me
with two small children now despite all
the chaos you're talking about to wake
up and work hard and perform for them
without the the the not knowing sort of
what's going on the uncertainty of your
future
I agree I agree now the final question
this is
this is I ask you blizz Blaine this is
me sir this is you okay West are you
sure I didn't get the last one right
yeah yeah we'll have the judges all
right is it more likely that the
conflict in Ukraine will end peacefully
before Pro producer Justine finds love
okay
let me read it again you guys
I think I got it uh maybe read it again
just to buy me time is it more likely
that the conflict in Ukraine will in
peace of peacefully before producer
Justine
finds love
[Music]
and do you know why you know why because
the war in Ukraine could end with one
single bombshell
the producer Jeffrey she's already a
bombshell
oh come on now
it is right there that's a cheers I love
America so much
I don't know who won I think we all won
America that's a winning day gentlemen
thank you for coming on I have a
question about camping for you guys
after oh yeah absolutely I can't answer
is yes
we'll see you next time on yes
or no
[Music]